الأجنبي
هو إحضار شيء جديد إلى
العميل هو مفهوم جديد تمامًا
لم أقصده أبدًا من
قبل في
هذا الخليج ، المفهوم هو إعادة إنشاء
ثقافة
العصور الوسطى
وإثارة ثقافة الفايكنج
أيضًا  في الواقع ، قمنا بعمل القائمة التي نظرنا إليها
حول النظام الغذائي للفايكنج بالضبط ،
لذلك بحثنا حول
نوع الطعام الذي كانوا يأكلونه ، وما
نوع المكونات التي كانوا يتناولونها
باستخدام تقنية ملفات تعريف الارتباط التي يستخدمونها ،
لذلك بالطبع لا يمكننا إعطاء
نفس الشيء بالضبط  الطعام الذي نأكله
لأننا في عام 2022 ، لذا ما زلنا بحاجة
إلى تحديثه ليكون المطبخ ،
لكننا نحاول الحفاظ عليه قدر
الإمكان ، فنحن
نعطي مكانًا يبدو فيه مظهره
وكأنه  ريفي ولكن لا يزال يحتاج إلى
الشعور بالرضا والجودة العالية ،
لذا فإن هذه المطاعم تأتي أيضًا
مع ميزات أخرى مثل الميزات الفريدة التي
لدينا على سبيل المثال Cutlass وهي عبارة عن
قواطع من العصور الوسطى ويتم
تشكيلها  بواسطة حداد يقوم بتخصيصه
لنا وأيضًا في الطبق الرئيسي نقدم
مجموعة من سكاكين الصيد حتى
نخدم ضيوف الشتاء الطبق الرئيسي ،
نطلب منهم اختيار
سكين الصيد الخاص بهم وسيختارونه
لأكل الفريسة ، دعونا
انظر وأيضًا ما يميز هذه المساحة هو
أنه يمكنك العثور على العروض المشابهة
التي عادة ما تجدها حول
العديد من المطاعم الأخرى التي يمكنك
العثور على العرض الذي يمكن أن يكون موسيقى الجاز
اللاتينية أو أي شيء يمكن للجميع
تناوله ولكن هذا شيء
فريد جدًا لأنه
سماع الموسيقى القديمة موسيقى القرون
الوسطى ومع آلات العصور الوسطى
والرجال الذين يعزفون
الموسيقيين المتخصصين في هذا
، وهم ينتمون إلى فرقة مشهورة من
أوروبا ، يأتي عرض النار جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الموسيقى كما تعلم عندما كان الفايكنج
ذهبوا إلى الحرب هم أول
ما كنا نذهب إليه هو
الطبول والموسيقى ، لذا كانوا يبذلون
قصارى جهدهم للذهاب إلى الحرب في
نفس الوقت الذي كان فيه عنصر
العنصر الأذيني الذي يأتي في الحرب هو النار
[الموسيقى]
إذا كنت تريد الذهاب لتناول العشاء وتناول
عشاء من القرون الوسطى ، فهو المكان الوحيد الذي
يمكنك العثور عليه الآن
[موسيقى] أجنبية